I'm not going to go over any of the
stuff that happens before they head to
the island as it doesn't really make
much sense to talk about a bunch of
random no names who were taken out at a
moment's notice while Gabby was being
held captive so instead we'll get
straight to it with all of the
absolutely useless characters that don't
make any form of actual impact in the
series first up on the chopping block
was the killing Buddha harubo his crimes
weren't even mentioned but the dude was
definitely the most murderous out of
every single prisoner before even making
it to the island and while sailing at
Sea harubo fell into his urges and
attempted to kill azachobe but failed as
he later managed to use an UNO reverse
car to free himself from the Monk's
restraint and take him out with ease
dude was overly eager to cause Havoc
which funnily enough backfired on him
making him the first death of the series
the next nobody akagainu was apparently
a notorious criminal who had a
reputation for Kelling and cannibalizing
men giving her the nickname cannibal
courtesan eventually she was arrested by
the authorities and upon sailing towards
the island akagaino had hoped of having
a retainer Shion become her next victim
how however after making landfall
quickly finds that Shion is immune to
her charms which weirdly makes her
excited to try out this new kind of
delicacy and one of the biggest owls of
the entire story she then makes her move
by trying to violate Shion resulting in
her immediate execution as the Blind
King never once even considered her
heinous advances okay so last up out of
the absolutely useless characters who
don't even do Bloody anything at all
funnily enough this man here Moro Makaya
is the only one out of the original
criminals to be constantly referred back
to so he is slightly important in the
grand scheme of things at some point
though throughout his life Makaya
developed an ambition to overthrow the
Shogun and win About It by forming a
cult that was based off a multitude of
different religions this led the man to
getting locked up and sent to the island
as obviously you know you can't be
challenging the Shogun for leadership
and all after making landfall Makaya is
probably subject to the worst Fade Out
of all of the original L takers he finds
the Super Soaker herself yusu riha who
actually wished to form an alliance with
him the two groups didn't end up working
together but the alliance that man
thought he was getting into was a it was
slightly different instead of defeating
every single one together as he probably
thought they were going to do he was a
uses his dumbass as bait to gain
Intel on the nature of the weird fauna
and bugs around him as we all know this
eventually resulted in his body becoming
a blooming corpse which was faced upon
by the centipede like insects and that's
an utterly terrifying way to go it's not
the way that I would want to go out at
all next up and the fourth candidate for
L taking is actually someone who
supposedly extremely strong the rank one
Yamada Simon Eisen so the day before
even heading off on a journey to Kotaku
Eisen informed his Junior shugen who you
know you'll hear more about later on in
this video sadly that he'd report back
to Japan on the second day but after
arriving on the island literally after
like his first few steps were made he
sensed a serious level of bloodlust
emanating from the mentally deficient
brute standing behind him like I forgot
can Roku Rhoda even spake after filling
this aura behind him Isaac immediately
goes to grab a sword and an attempt to
strike back but as he turns around to
swing at the Haven rohu Rosa blows him
away with a perfectly placed Palm strike
that vaporizes the top half of the rank
one's pathetic body so with the first
four discs out of the way now we
actually find someone who managed to
survive for a few minutes until this
mission's Expedition soon after arriving
on the island the beef cushion himself
warped Kion and counted Gaby marrow and
without a second thought attempted to
kill him with a surprise attack from one
of his weapons however he sees that the
Shinobi survived after he dislocated his
neck at will yes like he actually did
dislocate his neck at will here I don't
know why some of you Muppets see to my
arc explained video that he didn't it's
pretty obvious there if Gabby got hit by
the dude's weapon that'll probably take
his head off honestly the backstory to
this man is pretty dope it's not
elaborated on and the main story but the
reason this man fantasizes over his
weapons like a 12 year old girl is
because while undergoing training as a
sohei which is like a warrior monk Helm
developed an unhealthy Obsession for
them and decided to take his trainings
at the next level by slaughtering
martial artists including well-known
Master Swordsmen along the way he built
up a collection of weapons that he stole
from them which led us to where we are
now absolutely groaning in Anger that
Gabby manager Dodges first attack and
then convinces his next assault on Gabi
marrow by using weapon after weapon
until he notices that the ninja hadn't
even started to suffer any damage and
instead was mainly focusing on Ray tying
his hands as commanded by his assignment
earlier after finishing with this
bothersome task Gabi Morrow easily lifts
chaon using his Spear and kicks the
bladed weapon towards the criminal's
chest surprisingly and unlike everyone
else so far Cain manages to survive the
first lethal blow after revealing that
he had armor grafted to his skin
underneath his robes that are really
like a form of loving armor was he fight
kicking back off now though it's
revealed that in a matter of moments
Gabby Mario murk's Kion with a bunch of
his weapons next up on the list of
failed executioners who didn't even
manage to survive the first day on the
island was the retainer of the
previously failed criminal Yamada Simon
kisho what this criminal did kisho
simply rejected the idea of joining
sagiri and Gaby marrow warning her about
the criminals true natures and telling
her about the importance of this mission
for the executioners pretty much making
a small story like short here this trip
decides who will become the next head of
the clan and kisho wants and on that he
then left and made his way back to the
sherp while being stationed on the
evacuation vessel Keisha was eventually
infected with arabification and died
however this was all off screen so we
can't actually come to a solar
conclusion on who took him out but to be
honest it was probably something on the
ocean next up we actually had the first
death in this series that truly means
something and drives a few specific
characters like Shion and nurugai and
shugen to the next level Yamada Simon
tenza was only briefly in the series but
his attitude the way he constantly
challenged anything that came his way
and how we helped grow numerous people
after his death just like how he himself
grew in life is what makes him one of
the most important characters in the
story as we all saw in the anime tenza
did its absolute best to preserve his
Sensei and criminal's Life by putting
his own life on the line during the
first battle in the series against a
tension and after receiving a multitude
of life-threatening moons like Maine
literally got disembodied by a dow
strike to his gut Tinder desperately
tells Shion to escape with naruga as he
charges forward sadly and due to how he
received his previous wounds tenza was
unable to actually communicate this
properly however and because Shion is an
absolute G with a sensory ability he
feels that something's up and decides to
move naruga away from the saying even
though it broke his heart to do so the
station was Paramount to failing as a
human being in his eyes and because he
didn't have naruga's point of view as he
fled plus like the man's blind it
drastically affected him until the later
parts of the story where naruga told him
the truth about what happened the truth
was that Tinder stayed behind to
continue fighting the monster he
wondered about how his life could have
turned out in the future and Beijing
himself as an instructor of the Yamada
Clan like his teacher and possibly even
being weird to narugai and the future
moments later though and with a smile on
his face knowing that he saved his
friends tenza is then killed by the
tension Zu Jin next up and like I know I
killed a bunch of people misogynistic
throughout the manga explained video
that win over like a couple weeks back
as it was kind of the era that they were
all in at their time not necessarily
because they were misogynistic bad
people one of those people I did call
out though actually realized the
mistakes of his ways and how he was
treating siguri when all she wanted was
to be respected by a fellow Samurai of
course I'm talking about Genji who was
taken out in the battle against rokarota
by one of the Titan's Infamous push
attacks having received a grievous wound
to his torso but you know somehow not uh
not getting splattered into like your
old eyes and back there Genji ends up
resting himself against a trade to live
out his final moments scary rushes
towards and tries to give him some aid
while Gabby Murray himself keeps the
giant busy so remember like how he had
chastised her earlier and the story and
everything for not actually having her
blade well any time of need now Genji
gives his sword to zagiri and puts his
faith in her to execute Roku wrote her
hearing those words and like I said at
the start of this Digi finally
understands how Sega reveals herself and
gives her his sword after Gaby marrow
later sets the whole area on fire Genji
comes to his wound and dies in the fire
so during the same battle that we
actually lose Genji in there we also see
the passing of no one else then broke a
rotor the giant of bees in during the uh
heated battle if you catch my drift Roku
Rosa ends up falling for Gabriel's trap
to suffocate him using the smoke from
the surrounding forest fire falling to
his knees and unable to breathe it gives
to Gary a perfect opportunity to behead
him obviously Rojo Rota ain't no fool
and with how he'd like weirdly embodied
a weak and strong Spirit simultaneously
the giant properly was able to somewhat
sense agary as she went to attack and
immediately tries to attack her himself
to his dismay though Gabby Mario who is
actually cracked out of his mind and
deserves his whole video on manages to
hold down his hand and screams out for
zakira to make the finishing blow after
sagiri finally brings her blade down on
him Roku Roto receives visions of his
past of wanting to play and be read of
his hunger sadly for him Roku wrote his
soul is in late to race by siguri as she
tells him he may pass on In Peace So
skipping past there and with the death
of Roku Rota happening quite early any
grand scheme of things with the series
we surprisingly don't have anyone pass
on for a good while until the battle
with mudon after seemingly finishing off
Mudan Cintas sits down to rest with
zakiri and comments on how strong usury
house spirit is leading his fellow
Samurai to question whether he had
feelings for her Center denies for
speculation even though like it's
probably true and explains that he's
more jealous of yusufrihost innate
freedom and how she is able to be true
to herself while having the freedom to
lie to others hearing him sagiri says
that she sympathizes with him as
obviously it's kind of similar with
Gabby and comes up with a plan to have
everyone that came to the island work
together to survive Santa agrees that it
might work however yusu riha points out
to them that mudan's corpse is blooming
and in one of the most unexpected
moments it produces a stinger that goes
after her having since something was up
Center like the absolute Legion though
pushes her aside and is stabbed in the
Heart by the Stinger himself however I
say this was only a cup death is somehow
the G Yamada Simon Shion had managed to
show up and quickly Cuts away these
Stingers after also saving everyone from
the newly evolved kishikai modan moments
later he then orders nurugai to remove
Santa's flowers and Roots as he takes on
the monster himself yusu rihad then
gives Santa some medicine as well to
stop the bleeding but says that it was
honestly too late for him skipping forth
like slightly in a battle because you
know we're not going to go over
absolutely everything here Shion
prepares to strike the monsters Tandon
since though calls out to him explaining
that his true weakness is its ovule
located at the center of the flower
having gained this extremely like vital
piece of information she on listens to
Center and managers to finally kill
Mudan with mood undefeated the group All
Comfort seemed her they know that it's
probably too late for him to survive
when it comes to medical treatment so in
an attempt to ease his passing yusu riha
decides in helping him pass on by
telling him to think of something
precious to him for this last dying
Memory Center smiles thinking of user
rihar lying right next to him I'll go
over like a little bit more at the end
of the video on why certain deaths are
important like this one and literally
the one that follows it but before we do
that I kind of need to go over all the
debts that do happen in the series so I
don't confuse myself and so that you
guys get an understanding and you don't
get spoiled on like certain things but
yeah you get me you get me we're moving
forth following the defeat of lausanne
the other group of criminals and Samurai
end up reconnecting at the gates of her
eye after relocating to a nearby cave
hoko who if you ain't guessed it is next
up on the accent list sees that May's
condition is worsening and offers her
his Dow to help her recover May becomes
hesitant but hoko insists stating that
this was a way for him to atone for his
sins since he did not honor her wish to
leave the island and only wanted to
raise her as a daughter here instead
hearing this and also realizing
something within herself May accept his
offer telling hoko that she believes
they are like a family after absorbing
hoco's Dao Mei returns to her child body
and says goodbye to her father moving on
from May and into the midst of the
tumultuous like harai Arc where the
majority of the tents and face grave
losses here inside of the doing example
the formidable Imperial Monarch kundi
known as ran makes his tragic end and
they long fought battle against the
monster Debbie and usuryha employed
their cunning to unsettle rand's
kishikai State exploiting his momentary
confusion to gain the upper hand
throwing his leg impending demise Reign
desperately attempts to rejuvenate his
weighing down by shifting from yin to
Yang realizing the danger of rand's
resurgence Gabby Mario launches a
preemptive strike while also urging user
riha to deliver the final blow although
initially hesitant due to her own
injuries Yuzu riha publishes her own
goals aside and ultimately makes the
Fateful decision to end rand's life as
ran instinctively conscious spikes on
the ground to protect himself yusu riha
gracefully evades their lethal rage
lifted into the air by Gabby Mario
support voting the only sky and season
the opportune moment she descends upon
Iran obliterate in his hand and with one
of who Dao soaked kunai and his waning
moments Bran's thoughts turned to Rhian
wondering if this is what they wanted
before his final connection to life
Slips Away in another climactic battle
against overwhelming odds the fates of
delphar and juffar the two Tintin who
captured the hearts and minds of readers
with a unique Dynamic of being an
interchangeable bro insist who'd love to
partake in Crazy sessions of bochujutsu
take a tragic turn as chobe and Toma
joined forces with gantage of sight and
Fuji the fused form of jufa and Delphi
launches a face assault wielding their
deadly Vines Toby valiantly blocks their
attack but it is fucci and powered by
Thomas strength and doubt who strikes
the decisive blow swiftly retreating
back from it the kishiko monster barely
evades against exercise devastating
assault and instead adopts a defensive
stance shooting out some more Vines and
entangles the humans leaving the quartet
struggling to break free however gante
Jose's masteries of his abilities lead
him to a cunning plan descending into
the depths of the pole he Maneuvers
beneath Drew fire and delfa's fused body
before suddenly reappearing and
launching a powerful slash that saves
the connection between them vulnerable
and exposed they become easy targets for
chobe and Fuji who mercilessly destroy
this hand
emerging from the pole still like
somehow alive juffar battles with the
loss of losing his sister and with a
tatted body launches A desperate attack
on chobay and a surprising twist Trevi
reveals two stolen bottles of water Dow
obtained from Rhian and Dallas's juffar
preventing the Regeneration then and in
the overkill that Jobe was like
absolutely intent on here get hit decide
dartsen and cleaves the monster in two
and the afterlife due far remorseful for
his perceived failure to protect thou
far apologizes to her embracing one
another Delphi expresses her gratitude
for having Jew fire as her partner their
tragic death smuck the end of a
remarkable partnership between the two
and with the demise of these three tents
in here like including Rand from before
a massive section that was the hermit
power structure ends up crumbling so
back before shugen and everyone for that
team rolled up to the island and invaded
her eye we learned that the iwiga curry
Clan was going to send a group after
Gabby to ensure his demise while on this
ship and heading to the island under the
pretense of helping the Shogun we are
briefly introduced to Como Kitty this
man was a mysterious Shinobi of higher
caliber and had the authority over all
low-ranking genin Hill was also known to
be an all-rounder type of Shinobi that
was capable of handling a wide range of
missions along with shija who's like
that crazy chick that we'll talk about
more later kumukuri's overall abilities
turned out to be the second best when
placed next to Gaby Maru during the
adventure to the island kamakuri assured
the Yamada with him that she should not
worry about those from iwakukure and
their eyes Shinobi are viewed his pawns
towards their master and states that
they are free to select any one of them
to be thrown overboard or killed to
lessen their doubts wanting to see just
how far this loyalty of this wind the
kiyomara who is nearby and
listening to this order kumukuri to
commit Kuma side and a show of Just how
determined they are kumakiti gladly
accepts and passes on the leadership
position to shija he then uses one of
his swords to stab himself in the nick
while giving a chance fulfilling the
order that has been given next up we
just had like a bunch of random illegory
ninja some of whom were games like genka
Kobo kenka Kobo Nobu Suma and hakatage
but after confronting gebbie atop one of
the Palaces that make up her eye Gabby
and honestly one of my favorite sections
of panels from like the entire story
demolishes every single ninja who stood
in his way while at the same time
explaining to them what was wrong with
the technique I don't know why like I
know these deaths don't really make up
any kind of importance in the story here
but I just it's just hilarious watching
these Maniacs with a smile on their face
thank Gabby for like the beating he just
gives them moving forth now so this here
is another one of those times where
death and house Paradise is an entirely
for the spectacle so much happens that
grows like both Shia and the real guy
and even zujin's character throughout
this part during the battle and having
transformed into their performance-based
kishikai state zujin skillfully fainted
off the Relentless Onslaught from xion
and Uruguay a confident smile curled on
zoo Jin's lips as they taunted their
adversaries assuring them their victory
was beyond their grasp but in that
moment silence fell as xion's voice cut
through the ear like a blade your tricks
don't don't intimidate me he declared
his eyes burning with unwavering
determination with lightning crackling
in their palms Sujin prepared to unleash
a devastating Dow bolt yet before the
electric surge could Escape their
fingertips she on swiftly saved zhujin's
arm sitting at sprawling through the air
Shion his sword now stained Crimson
pressed forward without hesitation and
pierced to zhujin's Tandon undeterred by
the onslaught of vines that sought to
protect zujin's ovule she impressed down
rescuing his own life for the sake of
Victory but just as xion's resolve
seemed unbreakable nurugai displayed her
own courage leaped into action pushing
Sharon away from the blade she
interposed herself between the two
combatants through her words and
explaining the truth behind the death of
his disciple she managed to persuade
Shion to abandon his plan and reunite
with the Allies as he does settles and
the battlefield grew quiet the true
depth of their resilience became evident
as zujin somehow managed to survive and
eventually merged with the Divine Banco
surgeon's survival throughout the story
and the battles had they had were great
Testament to their like unyielding
spirit and want to be loved by the other
tension as I just mentioned with zhujin
after they ended up like fusing with the
Banco there causing the Pelos to be
blanketed with flowers fujin can teach
the size unconscious bodies become
covered in flowers in front of Shogun I
probably should have mentioned this part
but the reason that like they're both
lying here is for the fact that shugen
cut them both down but the only reason
that I haven't gone and like put it in
here is for the fact that it wasn't I
guess like a fatal blow in the end
anyway so standing there looking at the
flowers the iwakukuri Shinobi arrived to
give shuga the lecture of life and warn
him that Rhian is about to depart from
the floodgates shugong appears to make
his way to the floodgates and orders the
iwakuku Shinobi to confirm gante's death
underneath the flowers and to have
future be brought to him if he is still
conscious after shugen leaves shiju
reveals themselves and does the
transformation as a random Eva ninja and
throws two kunai to make sure that both
are dead before leaving somehow
surviving the slow like I don't actually
understand how they survive like this
part here Fuji wakes pick up on his feet
suffering from his previous wound seeing
as how ganti's Society is still badly
injured himself Fuji Masters up the rest
of his strength to administer first aid
after finishing healing his wounds Fuji
lies down slowly beginning to fade away
in front of Genki society and hears him
panicking over him after he wakes up he
also becomes delighted to hear that he
called him by his name for the first
time but knows that he doesn't have the
strength to respond back as gen tits
aside heartbroken carries his body fucci
and his last thoughts warns shugen to
not underestimate the survivor's will to
survive so after the death of Fuji we
actually skipped slightly forwarding the
story again and like now we're at the
battle between Gabby Maro and shija with
also like sigiri hanging over at the
side because you know she's a part of
this battle but she doesn't really do
too much this here is like a significant
turning point in this series as it
reveals the true depth of the
relationship between shiji and gabimaru
and the emotional struggles that they
both face Jesus death is a culmination
of their desire to be held by Gabby the
exploration of their painful childhood
near right and the Revelation that yui
gave you maru's wife is indeed alive and
unharmed despite the injuries shiji
continues to engage in this battle with
Gabby Mario they utilize everything that
they've learned from him in the past and
employ the fire monk technique sheja
makes a decisive strike towards
gavimaru's heart and actually manages to
pierce third which actually Garners
praise from him as if he was still human
this attack would have actually killed
him however Gabby Mario grabs shija's
hand and counter-attacks with his own
powerful nunpo acidic Blaze full of fire
engulfing shija and a torrent of flames
absolutely toasted by Gabby's Flames
shija just reflects on the time when
they developed feelings for Gabby with
the remaining strength they expressed
their wishes to Gabby's success and
create a whistle from their hair then
using the whistle shiju commands the
iwakukuro Shinobi to sacrifice
themselves clearing the path for
gabimaru forward shiju reveals to Gabby
that yui his wife is actually indeed
alive and unharmed by the chief what
happened there was like pretty much that
she just got put to the side and they
were waiting to get the confirmation
that Gabby had been taken out before
they doubt like the daughter and
everything and the last moments they
asked Gabby Morrow if he would fight
them again if they were reborn Gary
marrow who like obviously is probably
fed up with shidra at this point
responds affirmatively and shija
gratefully thanks him wishing him luck
in his future battles before passing
away so she just deaf like as I guess
random and unimportant as it may feel at
some points throughout the story is
actually a really poignant moment as it
highlights the complexities of their
relationship with Gabby Morrow we never
knew beforehand or before she even
showed up that technically Gabby kind of
had a little lover back in the past and
everything or this little girl who would
follow him around and pretty much do
anything to kind of be with him and
obviously you know like right on her
death you finally realized and
made the ultimate sacrifice to make sure
that Gabby could continue forth after
like the failing of zhujin's kishikai
state that we went over before and like
how I revealed that technically she
didn't actually die the events took a
dramatic turn as the entity that was
left over or like the head that was
slowly healing made its way through the
underground sewage system and eventually
found rhian's laboratory inside the
baked zhujin began fusing with the
Divine Banco bathed in gentle rays of
early morning light the amalgamation
under winter metamorphosis empowering
itself and becoming even more formidable
further on throughout the fire NSG
Canard the creature Unleashed a barrage
of attacks on him using its branches to
strike the area with a ferocious Force
however through skill I I guess chica
managers to casually evade the onslaught
narrowly avoiding fatal injuries a
multitude of times determined to bring
an end to the terror chica finds the
right location and launched a powerful
strike from a distance swiftly
decapitating the monster's head however
once again in an unexpected turn of
events the sun had actually begun to
rise illuminated the scene with its
radiant light and the monster's enormous
body which was seemingly destroyed began
to rise again its Tandon slowly
regenerating from the sunlight then and
another twist the unbreakable Spirit of
azatobe devised one last desperate plan
utilizing his command over the vines he
directed them towards the regenerating
tandons aiming to sever the roads that
connected them to the main body
after using absolutely everything that
he had left as a Cho Bay succeeded in
cutting off the vital length of
regeneration allowing the Banco to
finally disintegrate which brings an end
to zhujin once and for all here amidst
the chaos that happened throughout their
battles so Jin actually played an
unexpected role by granting go far a
glimpse into the realm of emotions later
leading to a profound understanding that
would come to slowly change him next up
and with what chobe had to do to defeat
zucchin and save everyone it resulted in
his body beginning to arbify having
exhausted every last ounce of his power
chobe collapses to the ground and by his
side he hears Tomah crying out to him in
that moment memories flood Chubby's mind
recall in a time where he expressed
concern to his parents about how fragile
baby Thomas seemed however he soon
realized that Tomah clung onto him
tightly as if his life depended on Earth
it was then that his parents reassured
him making him realize with joy that he
had become an older brother entrusted
with the responsibility of protecting
Tomer and the afterlife chobe is greeted
by the side of his parents and he humbly
Nails before them apologizing for the
sense he had committed in life despite
his remorse his Overjoyed to know that
he had been capable of being a loving
and caring older brother to Tomah this
realization brings tears to his parents
eyes and with open arms Chubby's Spirit
rushes towards them but as he turns
around he notices an unfamiliar figure
placing the hand on his shoulder so
after the passing of big chobey we get
honestly one of the most unexpected
gifts in this series like I doubt anyone
actually saw this coming I I know I
certainly didn't when I first read
through here so the remaining survivors
bartoma and a few others get at the
entrance to the floodgates before
entering inside the group sees that all
of these ships had been destroyed with
the exception of one but it is unable to
set sail due to the wreckage blocking
the water from flowing as giving Mario
sigiri and narugai all dive into the
water to make a desperate attempt at
removing the wreckage May despite
knowing the risk of her life ending
makes a decision to enter who kishikai
State declared a path for everyone using
her large petal Wings May blows away all
of the debris and gives everyone the
opportunity to hit towards the sherp
giving Mario yells out to me and reminds
her that as she stays in a kishikai
state she will die and won't have the
chance to live in normal life or see
Rhian and Joe fuku once more after
hearing him May breaks out of who
keishuka State and hugs sigiri and Gabby
Maro telling them both that this was the
only way she could take responsibility
and face with fate she thanks them for
everything that they have done for her
before she suddenly claps her hands
together revealing that this was an
illusion and she had transported
everyone to the sherp after the ship
leaves May's crumbling Soul apologizes
to everyone and the people that helped
her for not being able to flee with them
to the hoco to the tensions and to Rian
for not realizing how saddened they were
when they banished her and for not being
able to stop them in the past May's
death even though in my eyes it didn't
really need to happen just goes to show
that with care and nurture the tense and
can grow feelings they aren't just
beings with no moral compass and
feelings so traveling on the boat that
may transported everyone onto we make
our way onto the departure vessel in
which Rhian is trying to make their way
to Japan to enact the evil plan after
everyone begins battling just like May
it's revealed that Rhian had actually
put them all under a dow illusion and
when it's broken kiyomaro Isuzu and
shugen watches the various Fighters
awful victim to rhian's attacks having
watched a transform into its kashikai
stay and not wanting to allow the
monster to take away the Yamada Clan's
duty of executing the criminals kiyomo
and Isuzu receive orders from Shogun to
get the criminal safely on the other
boat however rain unleashes her power to
dismantle the exterior of the entire
ship causing Lumber to fly up into the
air taking Everyone by surprise as a
result kiramaru is killed after his body
is crushed under a piece of the wreckage
much to like Sakira and isuzu's shock
Isuzu like saying this rushes over to
their Direction however she has left
open to randstown manipulation resulting
in her death after her body was crushed
by the team sin now we're actually like
getting towards the very final last few
deaths of the series and when it comes
to ring him unbeknownst to everyone she
actually possessed an extraordinary
origin unlike her companions who were
composed of simple hoco and flower Dell
she was once a human this Revelation set
her apart from the other tencent who
couldn't seem to Fathom human connection
and instead infuses her character with a
depth of emotion as she still yearns for
her lost Humanity as the conflict raged
on the imperialist fate of Joe fuku the
arbified gold statue that Rhian had been
keeping hidden from everyone hung any
balance since then an opportunity to
break free from the chains of existence
Gaby Mara with an unwavering
determination charged towards Joe fuku's
gilded corpse intent on opelous racy
nerds however a momentary Poor's corrupt
him as he witnessed a vision an
aberration of his beloved wife and that
crucial moment of hesitation though the
Relentless Shogun the order 66 Merchant
seized the opportunity with a
life-draining stroke of his Dow infused
sword he cleaved jofuku's golden statue
in two severing his mortal existence and
ruining rhian's true plan to bring her
husband back to life as Rands guard
began faltering after having witnessed
the demise of her husband sagiri as
planned exploited the opening swiftly
and mercilessly who played pierced
through rain's plan I'll feel rendering
her form and two the upper half of
rhian's puppet body was sent soaring
through the air before plummeting into
the vast expanse of the ocean below
however William you know she wasn't
exactly done yet she refused to be
extinguished and was some form of like
miraculous resilience she began to
arbify enter an array of stunning
flowers that kept her alive ran then out
of nowhere Unleashed a devastating
attack upon zagiri catching up by
surprise and blowing open a
football-sized hole in her stomach
instantly fixing her gaze upon Gaby Maru
she felt that because of what he had
done she would strip away everything
that he held dear leaving him with no
hope of ever getting home again yet and
in midst of a vengeful Onslaught a
single question hung in the ear why why
did he hesitate to strike when Joe
fuku's demise beckoned Gary umaro
wounded and Resolute offered his
heartfelt response and that moment he
had glimpsed a vision of his beloved
wife and he understood the immeasurable
pain that she would endure if he were to
destroyed Joe fuku's face all these
words penetrated Ran's heart pissing
through the layers of anger and
bitterness as she stood there and golfed
in a tempest of emotions she suddenly
heard her Lover's voice suffused with
compassion and understanding flooding in
memories of the cheers moments together
surged forth it was in the selfless
instant that Ryan underwing a profound
transformation the love that she had
shared with Joe fuku and the empathy she
felt for Gaby Morrow's plight
overwhelmed her being and a final Act of
redemption and sacrifice she extended
her healing powers towards both Gabi
Morrow and sigiri mending their wounds
and dispelling the Darkness that had
consumed her for hundreds of years and
then just as swiftly as she had like
reappeared after segeri's last year in
half grian crumbled away into absolute
nothingness her Essence dissolving into
the fabric of existence so now with uh
Rhian and Joe fuku ticked off the death
list we actually bounced back into Japan
to join the moments like we sagiri and
Chica have them meet him with a Shogun
having found out about the iwiga curry
Chief's shame through Yamada samanjika
which was viewed as treason against the
Shogun The Irregular Chief was arrested
by the authorities as a result of the
chief being arrested the entire Clan
itself was dissolved and the chief
himself was put up for execution before
being executed the iruka curry Chief is
forced to consume the acquired elixir of
life you know just to make sure it's
safe and once he does so he transforms
into a tree his head is then finally cut
off of like the tree thing I guess and
then presented to siguri and Chica as
evidence watch also proved that the
story about him being Immortal was
absolutely false like I don't know what
Gabby was thinking that does bring us to
the end of every death that has happened
throughout Diego karaku or hell's
Paradise but before I do in the video I
do want to talk about a few different
things that kind of sat with me as I
read through this series and scribble
this video tins is death even though it
happened early on as a magic aspect of
both Shion and the rogue's character I
hope the two of them come together and
grow and to who we love allowed in
Uruguay to realize that it wasn't her
fault that her family died and when it
came to Shion he experienced a range of
emotions such as grief anger and guilt
probably some that he like he had never
experienced in his life before however
these emotions help deepen his character
and provided an opportunity for
introspection and self-reflection which
you know he definitely did and that's
why he ended up leaving the Yamada Clan
I I think I said it probably not maybe
not but hoko's death is definitely a
defining factor and may gaining that
Humanity Factor the final moment of like
her gaining Humanity in my eyes comes
when she gives up her own Humanity to
save everyone out instead of running
away like she had in the past but you
know all of the tencent's deaths apart
from Rhian are kind of void as if you've
watched my Full House Paradise explain
video then you'll know that goofah is on
his Revival Arc right now with that pot
that he found and re-ends like little
laboratory room in my opinion Isuzu and
kiramaru's characters were already like
subpar enough and their deaths just made
them that much more forgettable like
unless you look at like how hilariously
funny kills demises man was all taught
to be honest in the way that they did
die though I'm pretty sure it was just
done to expose rhian's rage for Gabby
and security to use later on while also
adding to like her overall strength
Feats now with Fuji's death this one
here I think holds immense significance
within the narrative primarily due to
like its impact on the characters and
the intricate dualities it explores
Fuji's demise pays off the contrasting
traits or beliefs that he shares with
Shogun and it emphasizes the depth of
their relationship additionally photo's
death also plays a pivotal role in Game
to exercise character development as
someone who had a close bond with Fuji
gentichai is deeply affected by the loss
of his friend through the aftermath of
Fuji's death ganttosite undergoes a
transformative experience unraveling New
Dimensions of his identity and finding
greater purpose in his own life but but
the dude literally goes from a master
swordsman to becoming a doctor in the
end it's the craziest 180 of a character
that I've ever seen overall the deaths
of significant characters in a narrative
hold immense meaning as they bring about
fundamental changes and growth in other
characters not every death and house
Paradise becomes a pivotal moment paying
off the contrasting Dynamics between
characters but the emotional weight and
impact of specific deaths contributes to
the series death and I think that's why
yuhikaku was able to create an amazing
story as like if I didn't really care
about these characters then what's even
the purpose of actually reading it
obviously if you all have enjoyed this
video then subscribe for more push this
video to 5K likes but for now it's been
your professional degenerate diavolo and
I will see you all in a bit bye